transforming into a new era is the main
title of this 20th edition of the doha
forum but instead of following the
original agenda with issues like
international relations food and cyber
security and climate change the war in
ukraine has dominated the discussions
the surprise appearance via video link
by the ukrainian president vladimir
zielinski highlighted that shift in
focus
zelinski compared russia's invasion of
his country to its intervention in syria
saying russia destroyed the ukrainian
city of mariupol in the same manner it
did to the syrian city of aleppo
he also called on qatar to increase its
output of gas to reduce europe's
dependency on russian supplies
this is also a question of abandoning
the usage of russian oil and gas
responsible states like the state of
qatar are reliable and solid exporters
of energy resources and they can make
their contribution to the stabilization
of europe they can do much to restore
justice
the future of europe rests with your
efforts it depends on your efforts i ask
you to increase the output of energy to
ensure that everyone in russia
understands that no country can use
energy as a weapon qatar's emir
mohammed al-thani who opened the event a
bit earlier said qatar stood in
solidarity with the people of ukraine
adding that the war there is a reminder
for the world to reflect on conflict and
refugees everywhere
we stand in solidarity with the millions
of innocent people and refugees who've
been victimized by this unjust war and
geopolitical calculations
while stressing the solidarity i would
like in this context to remind us of the
millions of palestinians who've been
suffering from the israeli occupation
and international neglect for more than
seven decades similarly a lot of other
people such as the syrian people and the
afghans for whom the international
community has failed to render justice
this year's edition of the doha forum
has come at an important time for the
world and instead of the war in ukraine
reducing the importance of other issues
on the forum's agenda it has made them
more urgent
the need to provide energy supplies from
outside russia has been discussed ceos
from exin and total energies renewed
their commitment to stop investing in
russia even if that might increase the
cost of energy
john kerry the us envoy for climate
change made the link between the fight
for the environment and the priority to
stop the current war in ukraine
it is the worst thing i've seen
and i fought in a war but it's the worst
thing i've seen
since i've seen clips of what happened
in world war ii
and it really rises to a level of
bestiality and personal craveness
that all of us should be
pushing back against in every way that
we possibly know
other how being covered in the forum
include the questions of refugees
misinformation and the war for truth
women's rights post pandemic business
models and artificial intelligence
mohammed al jazeera